قد لا تنجو الاداره الحاليه من تهديد
الرقابه والاصلاح الذي توعد به الجمهوريون
خاصه في ملف اوكرانيا اذا جاءت نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه لصالح الحزب الجمهوري
في الحزب الذي يحظى باغلبيه مقاعد
الكونجرس يسيطر على رئاسه اللجان المختصه
فيه التي عاده ما تعقد للتحقيق والمحاسبه
مكارثي الذي من المتوقع ان يصبح رئيسا
لمجلس النواب توعد بعقد جلسات استماع عن
قضيه الجارحه والمهاجرين غير القانونيين
والانسحاب من افغانستان وتحقيق وزاره
العدل مع الرئيس السابق
المحاسبه قد تطال رئيسا في النائبه مارجور
جرين
لعزل وطرحت 14 مشروعا لذلك على تهم
الانسحاب الفوضوي وتعريض حدود البلاد
للخطر على الاغلب سيفتح الجمهوريون ملفات
تركز على استيلاء الامريكيين من الوضع
الاقتصادي كما فعله في حملاتهم الانتخابيه
لكن هذه الملفات لن تفتح قبل بدايه العام
المقبل وذلك لحين تسلم وجوه الكونغرس
الجديده مقاعدها